takis candilis le numéro 2 de france
télévisions qu'on embrasse a fait une
annonce au sujet de fort boyard
oui le jeu présenté par olivier minne
sera bel et bien de retour à l'antenne
cet été mais il devrait subir quelques
modifications suite au corps d'un virus
regardez où vous explique tout ça
pourquoi fort boyard va changer et
comment fort boyard va changer regardez
c'est pas nous soumet au micro mais
pourquoi il a perdu son micro c'est
confirmé
les fans de mygales de vieux monsieur
qui donnent des indices et de vieilles
pierres vont être satisfaits
comme l'avait annoncé olivier minne il
ya quelques semaines les tournages de
l'émission fort boyard vont pouvoir
reprendre pour une diffusion cet été qui
chargent alors dans le parisien takis
candilis le directeur général délégué à
l'antenne et au programme de france télé
a donné plus de précisions sur les
conditions de ces tournages kiko vite 19
oblige ne se passeront pas comme
d'habitude nous utiliserons plusieurs
bateaux au lieu d'un seul pour rejoindre
le fort mais l'idée est qu'au-delà de la
sécurité des équipes sur le fort
l'exemple donné dans cette émission
familiale soit le bon on a le sens de
l'accueil what envoya un jeu que les
équipes du fort essaye d'adapter le plus
possible à l'air du temps nous avons
spécialement créé des jeux confiné qui
permettent de créer les gestes barrières
et la distanciation mais ce qui devrait
être le plus marquant à l'antenne ce
sont les protections que porteront les
candidats les candidats porteront des
masques et en même temps ce ne sera pas
la première fois que des gens portent
des masques dans l'émission c'est à
partir de mi juin que les tournages
devraient reprendre pour une diffusion
quelques semaines plus tard après on est
entré dans une belle dynamique ans à une
horloge serrée à laquelle les équipes de
production vont devoir s'adapter en
raison de ce contexte si particulier
alors là il ya plein de gens qui vont
nous dire ouais bon alors voix boyard
donc va comprendre ils vont avoir des
masques des conneries mais voilà ils
veulent absolument de revers qui leur
fasse parce que moi j'adore olivier
minne donc je suis content qu'on dira
fort boyard
j'adore le père fouras j'adore
passe-partout j'adore passe-montagne
j'adore passe temps j'adore pistes
partout j'adore tout le monde